It’s Halloween night in Chicago.
The stores along Main Avenue are leaving out
bowls of candy for the evening’s trick or
treaters.
Streets are closed off for the big parade
downtown, and young children are running home
from school to jump into their favorite costumes.
It’s a night of harmless, spooky fun for
most - But not everyone.
A police cruiser pulled up outside an apartment
building on Kenmore Ave, overlooking the Graceland
Cemetery.
A pair of seasoned officers climbed out and
made their way up to the thirteenth floor.
There had been multiple reports of terrified
screaming echoing through the building throughout
the night.
Was someone getting a little too into the
Halloween spirit and watching a horror movie
at earsplitting volume, or was this something
altogether more sinister?
The police officers approached the door of
apartment 1330B and rapped on the hardwood.
“Ma’am, is everything okay in there?”
No reply.
They repeated themselves, a little louder
this time.
They could hear movement from within, but
still, no answer came.
That was enough probable cause for them to
kick in the front door.
The officers swept the apartment, going room
to room, hands hovering above their holsters.
Kitchen: Nothing.
Bedroom: Nothing.
But the living room was a whole different
horror story.
To their utter disbelief, a human skeleton
was standing in front of them, holding a swathe
of flayed human skin, still dripping with
fresh blood.
The skeleton was forcing one of its legs into
the bloody sack, as though it was slipping
on a Halloween costume.
On the floor nearby, a pile of human bones
sat atop mangled flesh.
The officers gasped at the sight and the skeleton
turned to face them.
Without hesitation, it dropped the flayed
skin and lunged, wrapping its icy fingers
around their throats.
The rest was a cacophony of screams and gunshots,
which soon gurgled and choked into a terrible
silence.
An hour later, a team of forensic specialists
cordoned off the area while another officer
photographed the crime scene.
A pair of detectives paced around the apartment,
trying to piece together what happened.
A pair of armed, well-trained officers, strangled
with such force that their necks snapped,
and across from them was a pile of bloody
bones, meat, and human skin.
Before the detectives had time to draw any
conclusions, a group of black-suited FBI agents
arrived and ordered the local cops to vacate
the area.
They were taking over the investigation now.
Don’t worry, these weren’t agents from
the Unusual Incidents Unit here to bungle
this case further.
They were SCP Foundation field agents, undercover
and actively searching for a certain ornery
bag of bones: SCP-3114, a skeleton that the
adjectives “spooky” and “scary” don’t
even begin to cover.
But first, a question: Wouldn’t it be chilly
to have no skin on?
It’s an old nursery rhyme that you might’ve
heard during your childhood, and if you ask
our professional opinion here at SCP Explained,
we’d say yes, it would be.
And SCP-3114 can confirm this from first-hand
experience.
That’s why, if ever you run into it, it
may leave the encounter wearing your skin.
That’s right, SCP-3114 is a skeleton so
desperate to be just like us, it’s willing
to skin any human it meets and wear our bloody
pelts like a Halloween costume.
This probably leaves you with a very understandable
question: So, what’s his whole deal?
And thankfully, we have at least some of the
answers to that.
After conducting a series of cognitive tests
on the anomaly, Foundation researchers concluded
that SCP-3114 responds primarily to visual
stimuli, with its other senses ranging from
muted to non-existent.
If something even vaguely humanoid enters
its line of sight, 3114 will enter its rage
state, making a beeline for the victim and
strangling them to death.
Researchers believe 3114 chooses strangulation
as its favored murder method because it leaves
the skin intact, aside from a few minor bruises
and abrasions.
And once the victim is dead, it will begin
meticulously cutting them open and removing
their bones, again trying its best to do as
little damage to the skin as possible.
SCP-3114 will then attempt to wear the skin
as its own, eventually discarding it after
wear and tear sets in.
In one interaction, subject D-1724, an adult
male, entered SCP-3114’s containment chamber.
SCP-3114 attacked him, reacting with an increased
level of aggression when the man tried to
fight back.
SCP-3114 damaged the body of D-1724 to the
point that halfway through removing his bones,
it decided that even the skin was beyond salvaging.
It discarded the body in a corner of its enclosure,
placing sticks and boxes over it in what researchers
believe to be a form of pseudo-burial.
Tests on SCP-3114’s physical makeup indicate
that it is stronger and more resilient than
a normal human skeleton, owing to it being
made from a far denser material than non-anomalous
human bones.
During tests, researchers attacked the bones
with sledgehammers, power tools, and other
means of exterior impact, concluding that
it took up to three times more force to break
one of the anomaly’s bones than those of
a normal person.
SCP-3114 also has regenerative healing properties,
being able to mend broken bones at shocking
speeds, making the creature effectively immortal.
Even though SCP-3114 has no musculature or
connective tissue of any kind, its skeleton
is still somehow able to support itself and
move independently.
When a bone is removed or pulled away from
its place, it will quickly return to its original
position once a force is no longer acting
on it.
It also has far greater speed and strength
than your average, non-anomalous human, despite
its lack of muscles.
SCP-3114 also seems to have some semblance
of intelligence.
As an extension of its drive to appear more
human, it even has periods of dormancy where
it mimics human sleep.
Researchers have placed multiple items in
SCP-3114’s enclosure to observe how it reacts.
These items have included sticks, boxes, tires,
and building blocks.
A few experiments even involved placing live
subjects into its enclosure, often with predictably
violent results.
Due to the danger of being in proximity of
SCP-3114, Foundation researchers use projections
of humans to lure it into a smaller secondary
containment cell adjacent to its primary enclosure.
Foundation staff are barred from entry until
SCP-3114 has been locked in this secondary
cell.
Only then can items be added or removed from
the habitat.
Mess this up, and you’re all but guaranteed
a closed-casket funeral.
Something this strong and aggressive can create
considerable containment challenges for the
Foundation, so they started exploring a new
question: What can pacify this walking skeleton’s
homicidal wrath?
Two things, as it turns out.
The first is finding a skin that fits just
right.
Researchers placed a freshly deceased male
cadaver into SCP-3114's enclosure.
Naturally, SCP-3114 began to systematically
remove the bones of the cadaver one by one,
then placed the skin of the corpse over its
own skeletal frame.
SCP-3114 seemed happy with its new skin, observing
itself in a mirror.
SCP-3114 studied the reflection from different
angles, attempting to smile with its sagging
face and mimicking hand gestures one might
see in common social situations.
Intrigued by this development, researchers
sent D-4843 into the chamber to interact directly
with SCP-3114.
Upon coming face to face with SCP-3114 wearing
decaying human skin, the human subject became
terrified and attempted to leave the enclosure.
SCP-3114 persisted in trying to interact with
the D-Class, attempting a handshake and even
caressing the D-4843’s face, its stolen
skin sculpted into an unflinching smile.
The D-Class was not charmed by this.
Instead, he wet himself and was allowed to
leave the enclosure to change his underwear.
SCP-3114 seemed confused by the subject’s
fear and subsequent departure, waiting by
the door for him to come back.
It then grew frustrated and looked at itself
in the mirror again, this time reacting angrily,
and violently tearing off its skin, perhaps
made self-conscious by the D-Class’ reaction
to its new face.
From that encounter, researchers concluded
that SCP-3114 would not immediately attack
if it was wearing a skin that it deemed suitable.
The second thing that calms this bag of bones
is the companionship of man’s best friend:
That’s right, SCP-3114 has a proclivity
towards dogs.
This was discovered in a series of experiments
where the Foundation cross-tested the anomaly
with a variety of animal specimens.
The first of these animals was a gorilla.
SCP-3114 appeared to exhibit some hesitation
at first, indicating a level of recognition
between humans and our not-so-distant evolutionary
cousins.
But unfortunately, the confrontation ended
violently when the gorilla became agitated
and tried to exert its dominance over SCP-3114.
This led to a physical altercation where the
gorilla was overpowered and killed, though
not without breaking one of SCP-3114’s ribs,
first.
Thankfully, the second attempt at animal interaction
- this time with a Border Collie - went much
smoother.
SCP-3114 took care to be gentle when playing
with and petting the dog.
And even when the dog attempted to bite one
of its leg bones, SCP-3114 did not react in
an exceptionally violent manner.
The pair spent the better part of two hours
together, playing fetch and seeming to enjoy
each other’s company.
It’s comforting to know that there are at
least some things capable of temporarily taming
this stack of murderous calcium.
But what happens when it breaches containment?
This brings us back to our Halloween crime
scene.
An embedded field agent in the FBI introduced
himself as Special Agent Thomas Seward.
He spoke to the local detectives on the scene,
showing them a badge they didn’t recognize
and asking them to come downstairs to a mobile
office outside the building, where they would
be debriefed.
Members of Mobile Task Force Gamma-5, also
known as the “Red Herrings”,
were waiting in this unit to administer amnestics
to any members of local law enforcement who
knew about the case.
They would later also canvass the building
for other witnesses and make arrangements
to ensure that the bodycam footage of the
two fallen officers would be destroyed.
It was unclear exactly how SCP-3114 escaped
containment, but recapturing the subject for
the safety of the local population remained
of paramount importance.
With this goal in mind, agent Seward mobilized
MTF-Pi 1, also known as the City-Slickers.
A Mobile Task Force that specializes in the
investigation, containment, and subsequent
cleanup of anomalies in densely-populated
urban environments.
Under the guise of the FBI, the Pi-1 members
spread out across the streets of Chicago in
black vehicles, monitoring police scanners
for reports or sightings of walking skeletons
attacking the civilian population.
Meanwhile, several blocks away, SCP-3114 found
itself walking past a row of clothing stores.
It stopped at the sight of a mannequin modeling
sportswear in a window display.
Instead of charging at the humanoid figure
with lethal intent, SCP-3114 calmly walked
into the store and approached the mannequin.
It began to study the figure, taking off its
clothes and trying them on, piece by piece.
When it was fully clothed, it assumed the
mannequin’s pose.
It then began to observe itself in a nearby
mirror with rapt fascination.
A store clerk emerged from the backroom, noticing
that someone was trying on clothes outside
of the changing room.
He walked over to offer assistance but was
stopped in his tracks at the sight of this
strange new “customer” and the turn of
his bleached-white skull.
Not long after that, the anomaly left the
store, wearing the clerk’s skin.
As it emerged onto the streets, unnoticed
amidst the throng of trick or treaters, SCP-3114
took in its surroundings.
What a strange new world it’d found itself
in.
Then, it spotted a nearby group of trick-or-treaters
wearing various costumes, most notably a plastic
skull mask.
SCP-3114 had found its people.
Excited by the prospect of another walking
skeleton, SCP-3114 decided to follow the group
as they sauntered over to a larger crowd gathering
on the main avenue for the annual Halloween
parade.
Among the many participants dressed as werewolves
and vampires and other classic Halloween creatures,
SCP-3114 noticed a group of paraders dressed
as skeletons, dancing and walking together.
People were cheering them on, taking photos,
and smiling at the spectacle.
Perhaps it wasn’t so bad to be a bone-man
after all.
And everyone else at the parade had their
eyes on SCP-3114.
They didn’t see it as a violent anomalous
skeleton wearing skin stolen from an innocent
store clerk, they saw it as one of the most
brilliantly realistic costumes the parade
had ever seen.
People stared and waved and smiled in awe.
And SCP-3114 was loving every bit of the attention.
Soon enough, SCP-3114 was leading the parade,
waving gleefully at the crowds of impressed
trick or treaters.
It walked with the others for several blocks,
occasionally picking up fallen candy to throw
at the crowd.
“Wow!
Great costume!
That looks super real, mister!”
called a nearby 8-year-old boy marveling up
at SCP-3114.
“Do you want to come trick-or-treating with
us?”
He motioned to a group of 3 costumed friends
- they were all dressed as members of the
Avengers.
SCP-3114 turned its bony head, draped in stolen
skin, and followed the eager kids as they
began walking from house to house, asking
for Halloween treats.
Watching the children stick out their bags
and plastic pumpkins, asking for candy, SCP-3114
began mimicking the behavior.
It even picked up and started to carry its
own plastic pumpkin.
Meanwhile, across town, Agent Thomas Seward
was notified about a pile of bloody bones
found behind a counter in an up-market clothing
store.
Only one creature in town tonight could be
behind that: SCP-3114.
Seward made a call to all available Gamma-5
members, requesting a clean-up on-site and
comprehensive amnestic treatment for all witnesses
at the crime scene.
Seward and his team hit the bricks, searching
the surrounding area.
He noticed the large crowds leaving the parade,
with some adolescents marveling at the “amazing
costume that zombie-looking guy was wearing.”
And at that moment, it all came together for
Agent Seward.
“What better place for a monster wearing
human skin to hide than in plain sight on
Halloween,”, he mused to himself while unclipping
his radio from his jacket.
Seward ordered all available agents to converge
on the main avenue and search any trick-or-treaters
wearing any costumes that looked like rotting
human skin.
They were on the clock: If they didn’t get
to SCP-3114 before its current skin suit degraded
fully, it would claim another life tonight.
Meanwhile, SCP-3114 itself continued its night
out in public, trick-or-treating with the
group of children who were blissfully unaware
of how much danger they were in.
As they went home to home, the creature’s
costume started to take on a pallid green
complexion as the rot set in.
It gave off the most repulsive smell.
At some point, flies even began to gather
around it.
To any ignorant passerby, it was still the
most horrifying and brilliant costume they’d
ever seen.
And whoever was wearing it must have been
so committed to the character, because they
never said a word.
As the night wore on, the children each got
calls from their mothers, telling them it
was time to come home.
After all the obligatory grumbles, they gave
in and did so, wishing their strange, silent
friend in the horrifying zombie costume a
Happy Halloween.
This left SCP-3114 adrift, wandering around,
not sure exactly what to do with itself.
Perhaps it was time to find a new skin.
Maybe then, people would want to hang out
with it again…
The anomaly was distracted from its dangerous
thoughts by a dog barking on a nearby lawn.
SCP-3114 was delighted to find another four-legged
friend out here in the wild, and approached
to pet the tiny creature as it wagged its
little tail.
How nice it felt to have a familiar comfort
again.
That’s when it noticed one more little boy
wandering the lonely streets.
A new friend, perhaps?
SCP-3114 would follow him and see…
Just a few blocks down, SCP agents scoured
the streets with flashlights asking, anyone
they could if they’d seen someone wearing
an eerily realistic costume, with little in
the way of success.
Agent Seward was in the middle of questioning
a man who had participated in the parade earlier
that night when he got a phone call from one
of his subordinates.
Listening to police scanners, agents had intercepted
a call coming from a terrified mother who
claimed that a grown man in a strange costume
had followed her little boy home.
The agents immediately made their way to the
address, making sure local police were notified
not to respond to the call.
Upon arrival, they found that SCP-3114 had
broken into the family’s living room, and
was petting the family’s dog.
The skinsuit had almost fully degraded now,
hanging off the monster’s body like rotten
baloney.
They didn’t have much time.
Agent Seward had his men surround the building
as a containment vehicle backed up towards
the home.
They couldn’t engage SCP-3114 directly without
the risk of a fatality.
That’s why they’d fitted the inside of
the vehicle with a projector, just like the
one inside SCP-3114’s cell, to lure it back
into the trap.
Soon enough, just as Seward and all the others
had predicted, SCP-3115 began to angrily tear
off the rotten skin of the unfortunate store
clerk.
Its bones shone in the moonlight once more,
stained with blood.
The next person it saw would be dead.
So it was extremely lucky that the next person
it saw was the hologram of a male D-Class
standing deep in the back of the containment
vehicle’s portable cell.
SCP-3114 sped towards the hologram, grasping
claws outstretched, so intent on getting its
new skin that it didn’t even notice the
bulkhead closing behind it.
Agent Seward breathed a sigh of relief as
the vehicle drove off to the nearest containment
site.
But for him and the rest of his men, the night
had just begun.
They still had a hell of a mess to clean up,
and all this just so that murderous skeleton
could have a Happy Halloween…
Now go check out “SCP-060 - Infernal Occult
Skeleton” and “SCP-1123 - Atrocity Skull”
for more nightmarish anomalous bones!